how to win at stone skimming
with help from dr hugh hunt
skimming skipping ducks and drakes
whatever you call it
if you want to send a stone bouncing
across the surface of the water
there's a surprising amount of science
and technique involved
it's almost the same science that
allowed engineer and inventor
barnes wallace to create the bouncing
bomb used in world war
ii to attack german dams the so-called
dam busters raid
ok so first you need to find the right
stone
wonky shaped thick set pock marked
stones are
not recommended don't worry about it
being
perfectly smooth but the ideal stone is
flat and round
rather like a digestive biscuit though
maybe not quite as big
it just depends on the size of your hand
the key to a good throw is spin the
gyroscopic effect
stabilizes the stone as long as it is
spinning fast enough
preventing it from tipping over and
falling into the water
just like a spinning top has to be
spinning fast enough to stay upright
amazingly it's this same gyroscopic
effect that keeps the earth spinning on
its fixed axis in space
there are lots of ways to grip and throw
the stone but here's a good one to try
grip the stone with your thumb and
fingers with your
index finger around the edge as you
throw
bend down as low as you can and aim
towards the water
keeping the stone horizontal a good
angle for the stone to bounce when it
hits the water is about 20 degrees
at this angle even a beginner can get
away with a sloppy throw
but if you're good and you can throw the
stone both
level and fast then go for as shallow an
angle as you can
it's your index finger that will do all
the work generating speed and spin in
the direction of the two arrows
the whip of your wrist creates extra
spin
lift your thumb off the stone at the
last minute
get it right and you'll see more than
two bounces
who knows on flat water you might get
the stone to bounce
10 15 or even 20 times
but don't expect to get into the
guinness book of records
in 2013 kurt mountain man steiner from
the us
managed to get his stone to bounce a
record breaking
88 times
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already
hit the subscribe button and click the
bell to get a notification each time we
upload a new video